اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما كالعاده نناقش ابرز
ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
توافقون
نادر على انقره لماذا لم يعطي الامريكيون
والروس الضوء الاخضر لتركيا للقيام بعمليه
عسكريه ضد المسلحين الاقرار شمال سوريا
وما هي خيارات اردوغان في الملف الثاني
اتهامات متبادله بين روسيا من جهه
واوكرانيا وامريكا من جهه اخرى على
استخدام الاسلحه البيولوجيه في الحرب فهل
هي اتهامات حقيقيه ام مقدمه لتبرير
استخدامها وفي الملف الثالث تقريرا امامي
يكشف عن قتل خمس نساء كل ساعه على ايدي
اقاربهن ف نحن النساء وهل القانون كاف ام
لا بد من تغير ثقافه النظرات للمراه
[موسيقى]
في توافق ان ملكي روسيا نادر عارضت كل من
واشنطن وموسكو العمليه العسكريه البريه
التركيه للتواغل شمال سوريا حيث حذرت
الخارجيه الروسيه من ان اتخذها تركيا لهذه
الخطوه سيزيد من التوتر في المنطقه واضافت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان العمليه البريه ستؤدي
ايضا الى زياده نشاط المسلحين حاله اقدام
تركيا على تنفيذها واعلن المبعوث روسي الى
سوريا الكسندر لافين التيف ان بلاده
مستعده لتنظيم لقاء يجمع بين الرئيس
التركي اردوغان ونظيره السوري بشار الاسد
مع ربا عن امله في ان تتراجع تركيا عن
خطتها اما الولايات المتحده فدعت الى وقف
فوري للتصعيد شمل سوريا معبره عن قلقها
اذا الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره التي
تزعزعات وتعرض المدنيين والافراد
الامريكيين للخطر وفقا تصريحات برايسه
احاديث باسم ساره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ووفقه مراقبين تمثل هذه التعليقات
العالميه شده تمديد امريكيه بالعمليات
الجويه التركيه ضد الاكراد شمال سوريا حتى
الان
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
الدكتور بكيره مهدي اسطنبول للفكر ومن
واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
الشؤون السياسيه اهلا بكمين واسمحالي ان
ابدا من واشنطن معك استاذ عقيل في الواقع
واشنطن تتحدث عن رفضها لهذه العمليه
العسكريه همم حتى لا تكون هناك تداعيات
اخطر كما اا تقول امريكا الرسميه ولكن
مراقبين يتحدثون كذلك عن علاقه واشنطن مع
الاكراد همم كحلفاء لهم كما تسميهم ولكن
هل هذه فقط هي الاسباب او هناك حسابات
لواطن اخرى تمنع اعطاء ضوء اخضر لتركيا
لهذه العمليه
لا شكرا لك على هذه الاستضافه
بشكل عام للولايات المتحده تحالف معروف
ومعلن مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لواشنطن
موقف تقليدي تكرر على مدى السنوات بمعرضه
اي هجوم تركي ضد هذه القوات هذه القوات
جربتها الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
وهي تقدم خدمات كبيره للامن القومي
الامريكي لانها تتولى مواجهه داعش في تلك
المنطقه هي تعرف الارض جيدا واا مقاتلون
اشده وحقيقه ازالت هذه القوات امن كبيره
عن القوات
الامريكيه
وهذا مكلف سياسيا وربما مكلف بشريه الخيار
الاسود والافضل الولايات المتحده هو
استمرار سوريا الديمقراطيه تركيز على داعش
الهجوم التركي على هذه القوات
سيمنعها من التركيز على داعش وهي ايضا
قالت هذه القوات انها اوقفت حاليا مؤقتا
مواجهتها مع داعش ثم هناك سجن الهول او
معسكر الهول الذي فيه يعني بحدود 56,000
شخص كثير
عده اعتبارات استراتيجيه امريكيه تجعل
الولايات المتحده تدعم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتعارض هذا الهجوم التركي
عليها ايران
ضيفنا هو من تصريحات الجانب الامريكي همم
واشنطن ستعارض هذه الضربه لماذا تصر عليها
تركيا رغم معارضه ليست واشنطن فقط كذلك
حليفه همم تركيا وتلتقي معها في ملفات
عديده
للاسف الشديد هو الحليف الحقيقي في الشكل
الاثنين طبيعي هي الولايات المتحده لاننا
نحن لنا علاقات استراتيجيه وفي الحلف
الاطلسي
واتفاقيات ثنائيه كثيره مقارنه مع روسيا
الحلف او الدوله التي لها حليب فقط
1900 صحيح
على الارض السوريه لانكم اتفقتم في العديد
من المواضيع في ما يخص الملف السوري
واختلف ثم على هذه الخطوه
لا يا عزيزتي هو العكس للاسف الشديد
الولايات المتحده
باعتنا منذ البدايه نحنا كنا حلفاء منذ
اللحظه الاولى في حتى في التدخل على زمن
اوباما
وزيره الخارجيه الاريكلد وهناك لقاءات
عديده واتفاقيات عديده حول الملف السوري
والدول المنطقه كلها لذلك هو الخلاف حصل
فيما بعد بيننا وبين يعني الحليف الاساسي
الحقيقي الولايات المتحده ولكن التي بعدنا
عده مرات عده مرات وليس للمره الاولى
وخاصه في الفتره الاخيره يعني هي ليس فتره
الاخيره نستطيع ان نقول منذ 1993 الى الان
همم ليست همم جديد ولكن لا بد الاشارات لو
لو اه يعني رفضت ام لم ترفض الولايات
المتحده او همم
هناك قانون دولي الامم المتحده الماده 51
واضحه جدا
التفجيرات التي جاءت متكرره في الفتره
الاخيره همم يعني
لابد منها ان تكون رد وهذا الرد يجب ان
يكون بريا اا لماذا اقول البريا لان للاسف
الشديد الولايات المتحده تدعي بين الحين
والاخر نحن في شهر مي كانت هناك عمل
وتؤجلت بناء على بعض الاحتجاجات لاننا
حلفاء فا رضينا في ال في التاجيل بين من
طرف همم الولايات المتحده ومن طرف روسيا
هذا الطلب ربما همم اخذت بعين الاعتبار
ولكن هذه المره لن تؤخذ بان الاعتبار مهما
كانت الاسباب لماذا لان الولايات المتحده
تدعي بانها تحارب داعش ولكن للاسف الشديد
من الذي يحارب داعش واضحه جدا داعش موجوده
في الباديه الشام في منتصف سوريا وهذه
العمليات العسكريه التي
تاتي بين الحين والاخر من الحدود السوريه
التركيه الى داخل تركيا
ولقد صارت عده تفجيرات متكرره في زمن
السفير السابق فاس الذي كان ودعا بان لولا
الولايات المتحده تنسيق بيننا وبينهم لما
كانت توقفت
دكتور
نعم نعم
ايه فاذا كانوا يريدون حسب داعش لابد ان
ياتوا بهؤلاء داعشين على الحدود كما فعلوا
عده مرات في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
اييي
حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الوحدات الشعبي
الذي يدعون بان يقول سوريا الديمقراطيه
ويغتلونهم
ويقتلنهم ثم يقولون نحن نقاتل
صحيح
هناك موقف امريكا
لهذه العمليه العسكريه مهما كانت
الاختلافات بخصوص وجهه النظر ولكن
الاختلاف قائم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعارض هذه الخطوه واليوم وفاه امريكي
يلتقي قيادات من همم سوريا الديمقراطيه
لمناقشه امكانيه وقف هذه الضربه وبالتالي
دكتور عقيل الى اي مدى يمكن تتقدموا او ما
المتاح امام واشنطن فعله لساني لتركي على
هذه الخطوه
المتحده الكثير فيها هذا الاطار لاسباب
الاستراتيجيه همم هي ترفض العمليات تحاول
ان تتواصل بالطرق الدبلوماسيه مع الجانب
التركي لكنه اوراق الضغط التركيه هنا اكبر
الولايات المتحده مصلحه في دخول مثلا في
لندن السويد
وهناك اعتراض تركي وان ذهبت الولايات
المتحده بعيدا في ضغط على تركيا يمكن
لتركيا يعني لموقف يعني يتشدد بخصوص دخول
فنلندا والسويد في النوته بمعنى تستخدم
حقها الفيتو في الاعتراض على على دخولهما
وهذا يمنع هذه العمليه هناك ايضا يعني
استثمار في قضيه اوكرانيا وان اهميه ان
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الصفقه التي عقدت
معروفه والمتحده هذه الصفقه سخلت وجهلت
ممكنه عبر التعاون التركي يعني واستخدام
المياه التركيه
لواشنطن المصالح كثيره الان مع تركيا بسبب
الازمه روما الاوكرانيه وهي ربما ستكون
حذره في اللات تغضب تركيا همم
تركيا باستخدام هذه الاوراق
اعتقد يعني انه تركي ربما ستقوم بعمليه
بريه لكن ستحاولوا عشان روسيا سوريه تحجيم
هذه العمليه هناك مصالح سياسيه تركيه
متعلقه
بالرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان نحن نتحدث
عن انتخابات تركيا المقبله في الشهر
السادس من العام المقبل هجوم والظهور
بمظهر الرجل القوي بالقبر القيام بعمله
عسكريه كبيره يعني ضد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال سوريا تفيد الرئيس
انتخابيا وسياسين عده عوامل الان لصالح
تركيا
هل همم بس بهذه الملفات كما اا تفضل بذكر
الدكتور عقيل تركيا لديها ثقه في ان
واشنطن من بين كل الدول موسكو لن نتحدث
عنها لانه ليس هناك ضيف مطروح ربما في
حلقه اخرى ولكن هي متاكده انا واشنطن لن
تضغط اكثر مما يلزم لايقاف هذه الخطوه
فالوقت متاح لاردوغان للبدء بهذا العمليه
العسكريه بتعللت الاكراد كما يقول البعض
ولكنه مراقبين يقولون بان السبب الحقيقي
لتركيا هو احتلال هذه المناطق يعني في همم
مرحله اولى محاوله التوغل في مرحله ثانيه
مسك الاعراف في مرحله ثالثه تتريك الخدمات
والمدارس كما فعلت مثلا في عفرين
سيدتي العزيزه لو وافقت ام لم توافق
الولايات المتحده سوف تدخل تركيا في عمليه
بريه وافقت ان لم توافق لان تركيا تفهم
جيدا الخداع الامريكي مرات عديده كما شرط
لقد طلبنا عده مرات بان يكون توافق مع
الحليف ولكن هذا ليس حليب وانما اثبتت
بانه وعدو التركي اكثر ما يكون حديث لماذا
لان هناك القانون واضح جدا هذه القوات
تعطي السلاح والمال لضرب الترك دي ضربه
القوات التركيه في داخل الاراضي التركيه
وفي داخل في قلبي مدينه اسطنبول وقلبي
تركيه اذا الدوله التي هي ارهابيه وتساعد
الارهاب هي الولايات المتحده اثبتت بانها
ارهابيه وتساعد الارهاب بجميع اشكالهم
فلذلك تركيا لن تاخذ باين الاعتبار رفضت
ام لم ت وافقت ام لم توافق سوف تدخل بكل
ما تملك من قوه لانها فهمت جيدا بان
الولايات المتحده ليست فعلا دوله حقيقه
تحالف وصديق استراتيجي التغير بالعكس هي
تدعم الارهاب لقتل الشعب التركي
القناه
سوف يخدعوننا في الايام القادمه دليل على
ذلك لان ما حصل يعني كيف يقولون بان هذه
القوات التي قتلت في داخل مدينه اسطنبول
همم
مئات الجرحى وسته قتله وهذه ليس للمره
الاولى قبل ايام على الحدود وهذه كل بي
باموال واسلحه امريكيه واضحه وماذا نقول
لا شكرا لكم لا يا عزيزتي هم خادعون وهذا
الخزانه
يدفع ثمن
العلاقه التركيه الامريكيه هي علاقه اشد
عقيدا واعمق بين الطرفين نحن نتحدث عن
مصالح استراتي يعني تعود على مدافع 50
عاما تركيا اشتركت في كل الحروب التي
خاضتها الولايات المتحده ارسلت قوات تركيه
في كوريا في بيت نعم يعني في مناطق مختلفه
والولايات المتحده ساعدت التركيه في ملفات
استراتيجيه يعني بضمن حتى دخول تركيا في
النثر يعني بعيدا عن يعني اندفاعات
العاطفيه الحقيقه الامر التعاون العسكري
بين الطرفين وثيقه جدا متحده لديها قنابل
ذريه في قاعده بحدود 50 قنبله الذريه
للولايات المتحده في قاعده انجلترا مثل
هذه الثقه لكن هذه المتح اللي عليه حلفاءه
الاشد الصحيح العلاقات بين الطرفين على
مدى الاربع او الخمس سنوات الماضيه تمر
بازمات بازمات مختلفه
اتهام غربي لتركيا بتسهيلها بدخول داعش
هناك ملفات اخرى طبعا ترتبط بقضايا حقوق
الانسان بالتسبيح ذهاب تركيا استخدام
الاسلحه الروسيه اعتقد انه العلاقه بين
الطرفين امكن ما يجمعهم اكثر بكثير مما
يفرقهم يعني هذه اللغه الافلام
كذا اعتقد ليست مناسبه في الحديث عن مثل
هذه العلاقه بين هذين
الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
باختصار دكتور تفضل
يعني وزير الداخليه لما انتهت التفجير او
يوم التفجير قال نحن لا نكبر التعازي من
الولايات المتحده لان هي متورطه وهي
الداعمه الاساسيه في ضيفك يقول للاسف هذه
عاطفيه وغير اخلاقيه هل من الاخلاق هذه
الدوله التي تنتهي بانها تحالف مشترك مع
تركيا وتدعم هؤلاء الارهابيين والمرتزقه
منذ سنين لقتل الشعب التركي وليد ايه
لقيام بهذه التفجيرات وليست للمره الاولى
ولا الثانيه عشرات المرات هذه الاخلاقيه
وهذا التحالف وهذا هذه علاقه استراتيجيه
كما يتبعها بين هذه الدوله وتركيا
دكتور سيبقى موضوع للمتابعه والاكيد بانك
والدكتور عقيل كذلك ستكون معنا فلاح
اا حلقات وشكركم دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
في شؤون السياسيه ومن اسطنبول الدكتور
بكير التجان شكرا جزيلا لكم
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعد سنعود لنتابع
اتهامات متبادله بين روسيا من جهه
واوكرانيا وامريكا من جهه اخرى على
استخدام الاسلحه الجيولوجيه في الحرب فهل
هي اتهامات حقيقيه او مقدمه لتبرير
استخدامها